après la démission du conseiller général
UMP de Mantes-la-Jolie Michel violet une
nouvelle élection cantonale partielle
est prévue premier tour le 30 juin 6
candidatures ont été déposées dont celle
de Pierre Bédié ancien président
UMP du conseil général il avait dû
démissionner en mai 2009 à la suite de
sa condamnation dans une affaire de
corruption Nathalie Coste soutenu par le
Front de gauche le Parti communiste
Europe Écologie Les Verts Marc Jamet
conseiller municipal communiste demande
la jolie Cyril note pour le Front
national Éric Coty premier secrétaire de
la section locale udi il se présente
sans étiquette et ramassa pour le PS
suppléant de la députée de la 8ème
circonscription une réunion de soutien à
la candidate socialiste aura lieu en
présence de Benoît Hamon ministre
délégué à l'économie sociale et
solidaire le 18 juin une élection très
observée elle pourrait signer le retour
en politique de Pierre Bédié à l'époque
c'est Alain Schmitz qui avait été élu
président du conseil général à sa place